Ready. [inaudible] this is radio lab. I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
And on this show we've been talking about a memory,
remembering and forgetting him. Yes.
And this next story is about the most drastic version of this particular back
and forth that I can think of is it just can't get any worse than this.
This is a story of a man named Clive wearing.
It was told to me by the famous neurologist and writer Oliver Sacks.
Okay. First of all, who was Clive wearing when he was? Well,
um, he was a, um,
a gifted musician and musicologist who was really a pioneer in renaissance
music, especially the music of, of Orlando's losses.
Oh,
he had a group called the London Nassis Ensemble. This is Deborah claims wife.
And in every concert his signature tune was music,
had Daytona music, the Gift of God,
Boy Music, the gift of God. That's sort of interesting. And then what happened?
Then?
Vada suddenly in March of 85,
he became ill.
It began, she was just a headache
and he often had headaches because he often overworked.
So it was nothing out of the ordinary. But it didn't go away.
We called the doctor and the local doctors pronounced that it was a very bad
flu. Bark and nature of the illness was not clear. Uh, no.
It's gravity. Yes.
On the full fifth day of the headache,
he was suddenly out of it.
He couldn't remember things. He didn't know my name,
didn't know his home address.
The diagnosis was made of a herpes and cephalitis.
The damage had been done. It was left as Oliver,
but the most severe amnesia ever document.
[inaudible].
This is a man who at least when things were very severe,
would forget something in the blink of an eyelid.
It's very hard to imagine what this must have been like.
His wife Debra wrote about it though it a book for her own and she says his
ability to perceive what he saw and heard was unimpaired,
but he didn't seem to be able to retain any impression of anything from more
than the blink. The view before the blink, utterly forgotten. Each blink,
each glance away and back brought him an entirely new view.
Well, every moment is his first waking moment.
[inaudible] today was the first time.
There is no other moment for Clive except this.
In fact, I can't remember now what was going on this morning or I was here.
I've never seen thing.
This is Clive from a documentary filmed a year after he got sick.
That doesn't have any financial, anything at all.
I don't know what the hell's going on. What's wrong with you?
You can hear his wife Debra trolling for the umpteenth time to explain to him
what happened. I didn't want to talk.
This is one of the things that's wrong with you. These are not there.
I noticed he recognized that he away. He didn't know where.
I've been blind whole time. I've been dead for all time.
Notion to touch on that.
Then the brain hasn't been able to put the right time concerning the conscious
actually to the person involved with
not being able to store everything that you've experienced.
It's been not feeding. Wait [inaudible] not registering. That's right.
It's not making any impact and leaving a trace or an imprint on the frame so it
happens and then it fate.
Proust has a wonderful description of waking up from deep sleep in a hotel,
in a strange room and perhaps feeling confused and not knowing where you are,
what's around you or not even knowing who you are.
He says that memory comes like a rope,
let down from heaven to dwell one out of the abyss of and being
[inaudible].
No such rope is available for Clive.
That the staff at the hospital tried to help.
We put a divey by his bed and weird initially wrote in it,
you are in Saint Mary's hospital, Paddington. It is, et Cetera, et cetera.
Um, and then we encouraged Clive to, to write things down.
So he starts to keep a journal. Uh,
he is extremely intent on trying to document his state.
He is very, very precise.
He would look at his watch to see what time was this momentous event occurring
of first consciousness.
And so he would write down 10 oh six a week, first time,
and then have the same sensation but 10 oh seven awake,
first-time, truly awake. First Time. Ignore the last entry.
Now I'm awake. This is the first real awakeness. And so the,
the diaries are line by line,
a succession of astonished awakenings.
People's interest in the diarrhea. Rubbish. What does that mean?
[inaudible] did you write that up? No. Conscious to the
[inaudible] [inaudible] for the first time. Is it, is it your handwriting?
I know nothing about it at all. So how do you think it got there?
I did to do the doctor didn't know, but you must know.
I haven't seen the book of total now. No, I'm all I'm saying that's me.
That means I haven't seen it yet. I have no knowledge over the door. That's all.
There's no knowledge of that book. The world is entirely new to me.
But you put who would put that? I didn't know that. No, no, no, no. Oh,
I have to say usually judges
[inaudible] it seems as about as horrible as anything I could imagine. Yes.
Clarify gets a sense of, of deep Hala. Many, many times a day. Shame is death.
New Difference Between Day and night. No thoughts at all.
No one quite knows what to do with someone with Amnesia.
I've never seen any human beings since I've been here.
I don't remember sitting down on this chair. If they're not mad,
they're not retarded. [inaudible] death.
Clive has now suffered with this total Amnesia for more than 20 years.
Pretty much, right? Have One night, 20 years long with no dream.
That's what been life just like this
is that since we in totally painless
and yet some,
some things have sustained the love he has for his wife,
Deborah remained part of him even though he doesn't remember, for example,
his children's names,
he doesn't remember anything about his immediate past or even his relatively
distant past. When Deborah walks into the hospital room and he sees her,
what happens? He gasps
with relief and excitement
and they hug and he kisses her with with enormous passion.
He is suddenly being rescued from the abyss.
There's suddenly something and someone familiar
and I don't see you in Toronto. Anyone at told told them
[inaudible]
when she goes home and the phone is ringing,
she's just visiting [inaudible] and she,
you may find too, she might find 20 calls on on on the message machine
from a man who doesn't know she's,
I told him, go ahead. Don't let anybody in this way.
I know nothing about this. Always wants me to basically Kinda
[inaudible] post recap a hundred Kevin, everybody else and we'll talk to you.
Please, please come 14 minutes later.
That's his quiet head. I don't want to speak to, I'll say my CTU darling. Okay.
CVPs senior yet. I want to please come down here. Bye Bye.
You live in minutes later. This is Scott. Yeah, I've not,
it wasn't a gap anyway. You can get to me. It's not the place to come.
I don't see you doubting it. Five here.
I don't care about anyone else. Alright. Yeah. No. In case you don't recognize,
he does not remember her in every way.
He may fail to recognize her if she just passes. He cannot describe her.
He may forget her name, but he does not forget her. Embrace her warmth,
her love, her kisses, her caring for him.
Sure. The question is what happened here?
Did he could forget everything it seems, but not her.
When I asked Oliver, he referred to an experiment in particular,
well this was a famous or infamous experiment done by collaborate,
who was a French neurologist at the beginning.
And this was done at the beginning of the 20th century. And there's this famous,
a patient who basically had a version of the, uh,
of a memory problem that was in the film. Momento that's science writer,
Steven Johnson.
Basically she couldn't remember anything longer than kind of five or 10 minutes.
It would just disappear and everyday should we go see your doctor and he would
greet her and she would say hello and introduce herself. And he would say,
well we see each other every day. But she would, she wouldn't remember.
And then one day,
this is kind of a funny story cause it's not exactly what you want your doctor
doing. One day what he did was he concealed as he was shaking your hand,
he concealed a little thumbtack in his palm and reached and shook her hand and
pricked her hand and she recoiled and said, well, you're a terrible doctor.
And then the next day when she came back again and didn't know who he was,
didn't recognize him at all as usual and said hello and introduced herself.
And then he reached out to shake her hand and she paused and she had this
instinctive kind of feeling like there's some kind of threat here.
If she had no memory, if she could remember who this guy was,
how could she somehow remember this, this threat,
the threat posed by the pinprick in the palm? Well, this sounded for his notion
and then I think memories of,
of pain and joy I think are sort of primordial
down in the oldest parts of our brains. Oliver things,
it may be a place for the memories that matter the most.
I liked the idea of a sort of sub-cortical safe vault
for Clive,
protected in the vault out of reach from his Amnesia was love for his wife and
one thing more. Yeah.
I taken him off the ward to get some peace because he was hyper sensitive to
noise and uh, the most peaceful place I happened to be the chapel.
Um, we picked up an old hymn book and for launch event,
anything better to do and because Clive talked jumble most of the time,
at that stage,
I began to sing and all of a sudden like it was the most natural thing in the
world. He joined in
[inaudible]. He could sing
[inaudible].
I was amazed that he could still beat music and sing.
It wasn't a tentative sort of stumbling, falling off a log, full voice,
strong everything. Yep.
[inaudible]
well, I will say, well, I want to sing another. Oh, you bet. Yeah, absolutely.
If he could do that, she wanted double. What else could he do?
We even brought his quiet in the,
when he used to conduct in London's to the hospital chapel.
I had a hunch that if we stood Clyde in front of them with a piece of music,
he would be able to conduct,
and it happened just as I taped.
His singers were flabbergasted.
There was that old conductor bringing them in completely and utterly himself
and almost the instant it was over, it was over.
He had no memory what he'd just done. In fact,
later on she showed him a tape of that very performance.
What would you say if I told you you conducted the last ensemble, please
cue me to prove it.
[inaudible] [inaudible] the space right in front of them are on the pedestal
and he's conducting, he is fully in the new music,
SUNY himself.
So music Hattaway becomes this Houstonian remote from heaven,
which will the him to himself and no one really knows.
I remember that. Now
music does that makes this possible, not just in club and many others.
Maybe it's something about music itself that it's so richly organized and every
time you eat a song you can feel what has been and what's about to be
bebe. I was just carried along in the architecture of music,
but when the music stops,
he fooled out of time.
Music gives him a piece of time in which to be accessed
out of time, out of memory, out of himself.
There's two things left. There's love and there's the joy of music.
Everything else is gone, but for some reason,
those day, thanks to Deborah wearing,
she's written a book about Clive called forever today,
a memoir of love and Amnesia. Thanks also once again into Oliver's sacks,
who's included a piece about Clive in his new book on music and memory called
Musicophilia and thanks to [inaudible] and associates,
producers at the 1986 Jonathan Miller, documentary, equinox,
prisoner of consciousness.
That's our show for today. Yep.
It never fear if you didn't absorb everything you just said,
because you can always go to our website,
radiolab.org we will give you links there to any of the books that you just
mentioned. [inaudible] subscribe to the podcast, right? Yes.
radiolab.org or go to iTunes. Oh, one more thing. Oh,
you can send us an email to please radio lamp@wnyc.org that's the email address.
I'm chat. I'm Ron and I'm Robert Village. And this was radio lab.
Three new messages. Message one,
it's produced by Jared, a boomerang,
senior producer Ellen Horn. I see. Same producer, Lola mailer,
production executive. Then Capella contribution.
Edito [inaudible] learn production support by Saddam for the cranium.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Mark Phillips message too.
Hello, this is your computer hard drive.
Thanks also to Trent Welby [inaudible] jockey it
[inaudible] special thanks to Greg gassed. I really know Andy landside.
Eric, John, Vince Guardino, Roderick though.
Alan Smith and Penguin Lorraine madox.
Thank you. Also for Justin Paul Carter Lane Moses in Tierra.
It's viral Louis [inaudible] name colon and crystal.
The fame special things to manger Shapira at the end before the video superstar.
And special thanks to me and I use it.
Office furniture place good quality in the best prices in New York City
and thanks to me in the computer on a, in the few.